each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so for this last session we have a
couple of very good colleagues of mine
who are the co-directors of the
Pittsburgh supercomputing Center Michael
vine Carnegie Mellon and Ralph Ross keys
from the University of Pittsburgh and of
course as the directors of one of the
country's major super-convenient
centuries they are as you might imagine
thinking very hard about you signs and
about the emergence of data intensive
computing and its importance incentive
discovery and so Ralph crosskeys will
give some of their thoughts about this
well ok thank you very much so as those
of you who don't know Michael and Ivan
co-directors of the Center for since it
started 23 years ago and we seem to be
interchangeable in many venues and so
we've appeared on committees as my cross
keys or Ralph Lavigne or something like
that so I've been chosen today to
actually deliver the talk but it's on
behalf of both of us and it's about the
role of data in NSF in NSF thinking
about cyber infrastructure I'll start
with a brief review of the history of
the NSF supercomputing program which
began in 1985 and it is the method by
which primary access to the large-scale
computational power is provided to the
national academic research community and
there are other people that provide high
performance computing cycles notably do
II and so on but those are mostly
mission specific efforts although lately
the deal we has expanded its access to a
broader set strangely enough NIH has
declined to provide super computing
resources although they supply provide a
lot of support for people work and so on
if you want I can talk about that some
later in the question period if you want
and supercomputing I'll interpret
to be broadly construed to include
networking and storage and visualization
and application development and so on
and I must say them in huge developments
in in the time that we've been in
business a factor of ten to the sixth in
the strength of computing power measured
in flops and scientific payoff in
virtually every field and i created this
slide a few years ago we've had 11
supercomputers here in the history of
the supercomputing center i showed the
first ten of them here and in each case
i can point to applications that were
enabled by the increase in computing
power now as i keep telling people
touring show that you could do
everything on any computer you wanted
but to make it feasible in terms of
either the time to solution or that the
memory that you need in order to get the
necessary resolution and things like
that it's quite remarkable and it's in
all sorts of fields atmospheric science
materials heart modeling molecular
biology astrophysics and so on
organizationally it's interesting just
for a moment to talk about that the
high-performance the supercomputing
program began in the office of the
director at NSF and soon thereafter it
got put into the division as a division
at NSF instead of an office and in the
Directorate that had to do with
computing and that was an uneasy
marriage for the time that it went on
because fundamentally what computer
science was interested in certainly in
the 80s late 80s Early 90s the
development of Internet and so on I was
not really what the supercomputing
centers were doing and the customers
were outside of the computer science
community so recently they moved it back
as an office now of cyber infrastructure
which again reports directly to the
director of NSF and they see high
performance
shooting more broadly as piece of an
essential infrastructure for the country
and if you listen to Ed's Adele who
until very recently was the director of
the office of cyber infrastructure he
talks very much about the centrality of
data as one of the main drivers for
cyber infrastructure and ironically this
move from out of the Directorate that
deals with computer science back to the
office reporting directly to the
director happened just at a time where
this increase in in emphasis on beta is
becoming much more relevant to what it
is that computer scientists are worried
about but that's just the irony now the
drivers you've heard a lot of that from
this conference why are we paying why is
NSF paying a lot of attention to data
and its importance in scientific
discovery there's been a lot of things
presented at this meeting on genomics
I'll show you some just rough measures
of data flows for example that are
supposed to emerge from the Large Hadron
Collider at CERN from huge astronomy
databases from large-scale simulations
and we're expecting it in increasing
number of fields so here's a slide i got
from Paul Avery this is just one of the
experiments at CERN there's data being
generated from the online from the from
the physics of the detection system
going to the certain computer center
where it then gets massaged and of
course greatly increased and we're
talking about sustained data rates where
people are where they're sending out the
results for further analysis around the
world at tens of gigabits per second
sustained the another example is
astronomy and this is a picture of
a representation of a telescope which is
going to be finished and put into
operation in 2013 the data rates are
pretty daunting they're going to do 20
terabytes of imaging every night they
have to monitor a lot of variations in
real time they'll be producing petabyte
catalogs in database systems every year
and they figure they will have
accumulated something like 60 petabytes
of data in databases at the end of the
project which is someplace between 10
and 15 years so very large amounts of
data and I'll come back to that we heard
in this meeting of interesting work by
the people at Harvard on transmission
electron microscope data just as an
example they have been transferring data
to the Pittsburgh supercomputing center
for further analysis and they take a
bunch of sections of brain and and then
they want to register this and construct
a volume and the ID goal is eventually
to see individual neurons through the
brain volume they've been transferring
at that to that data to Pittsburgh 4d
warping primarily and they've moved 110
terabytes of data to us to do this kind
of analysis over network so it's very
large amounts of data not a huge amount
of computing actually once you get the
data but it's interesting another
example now coming for those were things
generated by instruments now if I talk
about things generated by simulations
look at seismology for example there are
two major groups doing seismology
simulations ones here at Carnegie Mellon
called quake and there is a group at the
Southern California earthquake Center
that has a similar but different code
called awm and they're producing outputs
that are superb
presumably based on the same inputs but
with slightly different algorithms
involved and they want to compare the
results to see whether or not they're
consistent with each other so if you
were to do a voxel voxel comparison I
mean it just wouldn't work so you need
data intensive statistical analysis
tools and the data sets are really huge
they're hoping to do they haven't yet
done it at quite this stage they're
already at the tens of terabytes scales
but they're hoping to do an analysis
about 200 seconds of shaking on a
simulation with the frequencies all the
way up to 2 Hertz two Hertz is a
frequency that matters for people who
build buildings and so the in fact the
group at Carnegie Mellon is the civil
engineering group interested in this and
I'll come back to this but again we're
talking about hundreds of terabytes of
data and statistical analysis techniques
required and in the building of this
LSST telescope detector you have to do a
lot of simulations that require you to
cut through cosmological simulations
where you you do time stepping in
cosmological simulations but then you
want to take a look at something like
lensing which requires you to take a
current point and move it backwards in
time to see how the light progressed
from that source to what we see today
and so you have to put together a lot of
these time slices and the universe is
roughly 30 terabytes of data at the
scale which people are doing those
simulations now so this is just to
indicate that there's lots of large data
projects that are of interest to science
and there are various resources
available there's a there's loosely
coupled distributed resources there of
course resources at individual campuses
there are farms Condor farms for example
at a particularly large one at Purdue
where they have on the order of seven
the seven thousand machines hooked
together as a condor resource the large
investments that NSF has recently made
which were selected primarily not on the
basis of whether they're good for large
data analysis but rather whether they're
good for large floating point
calculations there's one at texas which
is 579 teraflops in peak performance
63,000 cores and then more recently at
the university of tennessee and the
machine which is pictured here is
actually at Oak Ridge almost a hundred
thousand cores and a petaflop peak I
mentioned to you that the increase in
computing power is about a factor of 10
to the 6th when we started we had a Cray
ax MP cost 20 million dollars here at
Pittsburgh its peak speed was under a
gigaflops oh there's a factor of 10 to
the 6th there that we've gotten in 24
years of operation and what's coming in
two years time at Illinois is this
machine called blue waters it's an IBM
machine which is essentially going to be
ten petaflop speak and we don't have a
lot of details about that machine but
that that much about it is known so
what's missing and what we found based
on discussions with many communities is
that we need a complementary
architecture I should go back and say
these two machines the Texas machine and
the Tennessee machine are by far the
largest resources in the in the NSF
program and the way they're programmed
is essentially by MPI these are
distributed memory machines with message
passing as the traditional programming
paradigm and what we think is required
is a complementary architecture with
very large shared memory and as was also
mentioned several times in this meeting
you need to worry a lot when you have
large data about I
oh you have to worry about it internally
just between your machine and your disc
farm and also how do you get the data so
you have to worry about wide area
networks as well and we need to find
ways of making more innovative use of
wide area networks the networking guys
tell us that they can do all this but
somehow we haven't gotten around to
actually exploiting it very well and
large-scale database systems I'll talk a
little bit about shared memory now
because there's a great number of
applications where shared memory would
really be very useful as opposed to the
large distributed memory machines that
have been available I'll give you some
examples in a moment from sort of
traditional science but there is a very
large number of graph algorithms that
really require to you to do pretty
random accesses where the shared memory
is very useful and this is the area
where the computer science community is
much more interested than they have been
in the past in these kinds of large
machines you can to do web analytics to
study security machine translation
marketing so on we also if you're going
to do data rich applications the way in
which you do data analysis is is in some
sense is quite different from the way in
which you do a large number of
simulations and that is you don't know
exactly how to look at the data and
you'd like to try quick and dirty
methods for seeing if their signals if
there are patterns that you can discover
and so on so ease of programming is
something which is really important you
would like to be able to throw together
a program in half a day and try
streaming a data set through it to see
if there's any really good signal in
there of something useful as opposed to
spending a month or three months writing
a carefully crafted MPI program and
experiences that OpenMP which is the
shared memory
computing paradigm that we use to
exploit the parallel ISM if people find
it much more easy than than MPI to use
so again the shared memory is important
and then a lot of the statistical
algorithms that exist again favor at
large memory so coming back to this
seismological example in order to do
this statistical analysis to see whether
or not you're getting roughly the same
predictions from the the two different
models or the two different ways of
doing the seismic modeling you can't
just take the same time slice and look
at each each group's predictions because
they could be off a little bit in their
time evolution calculations and so you
have to look at a whole series of time
slices at one time in order to see
whether you can it basically change the
phase slightly and make these two groups
align very well with each other and to
do that you need these substantial
windows of time slices which takes a lot
of memory in order to do this and
similarly as I mentioned in the LSST in
order to go back in time and look at the
the lensing issue you have to have a
large part of the simulation in memory
that you can trace back to do these
lensing calculations another interesting
development is computational
epidemiology which is an agent-based
simulation based simulations these days
and typically they find again that the
shared memory parallelism is is what is
needed in order to do this thing
effectively and the kinds of memories
are talking about is 70 to 80 gigabytes
of shared memory I mentioned this
particular example because this effort
is actually supported by the Gates
Foundation there's a major grant to the
universe
city of Pittsburgh to the Graduate
School of Public Health there to study
epidemiological modeling and the super
are the Pittsburgh supercomputing center
is involved in that effort so we realize
this about large shared memory and
recently about a year and a half ago we
bought a modest on the scale of large
NSF investments a machine that had one
and a half terabytes of coherent shared
memory and since its introduction that
machine has been very much in demand by
the national community and in addition
to the traditional areas where people
had been doing work in the NSF program
we've seen work in new areas
particularly of interest to computer
scientists and some of you who were next
door at the previous session heard the
kidney exchange talk by Thomas son home
but he's also one of the experts he's
done remarkable work in poker and poker
is a different kind of AI problem
because as opposed to typical games like
chess or so on you don't have complete
information about what's going on and
it's and it's quite different and
evidently the search spaces is much
bigger and so on I've mentioned
epidemiological modeling there are
people doing social network analysis
there was a paper that i found
revolutionary in science earlier this
year by tom mitchell and the group on
cognition and functional magnetic
resonance imaging that has used these
resources and so on so data of course
has lots of different aspects you can
talk about the storage of it you can
talk about analysis techniques you can
talk about IO rates you can talk about
as I've mentioned already large memories
and then there are things like databases
curation and so on and all those things
are of interest to the NSF so let me
mention some of their recent investments
which are focused explicitly on data so
there was a competition for what was
called a data
intensive system and it was won by the
San Diego supercomputer center
interestingly just so you may think that
they haven't quite gotten it yet in the
solicitation the only requirement on the
machine was that it had 200 teraflops of
floating-point power was supposed to be
a data machine and nevertheless they
wrote in that the requirement was 200
teraflops the machine I know its name
it's going to be called Flash Gordon
presumably because it has some flash
memory in it the details of that machine
are not yet public it doesn't it's not
up there yet but the award has been made
and it's likely to include software
based shared memory there are two
systems that are called data and
visualization systems but the emphasis
has been primarily on data I mean on
visualization I'm sorry and one of them
is at the University of Tennessee and
their plan is to again these are systems
that have been funded but don't yet
exist their plan is to buy a system from
SGI thousand twenty four processors four
terabytes of shared memory remind you
the machine we have is one and a half
terabytes but just to show you and this
is a machine with ten teraflops of
compute power whereas the the conditions
on the data machine was that it has 200
teraflops of compute power and one of
its great advantages is that it is
co-located with the very large
supercomputer that they have at
Tennessee so that you could simulate
data put it up put the data up on the
file system do the analysis on this
other machine and not worry about
large-scale transferring of data and
similarly in Texas they are putting up a
system it has a lot more GPUs in it it
has what 256 times 2 512 GPUs
whereas the Tennessee machine only has
16 GPUs but the machine in in Texas is
again distributed memory whereas the
machine in Oak Ridges in Tennessee is as
I say four terabytes of shared memory
now there's also the question of how you
preserve data how you store it and
preserve it and one of these
solicitations that NSF has put out is
called data net and the idea is to study
sustainable digital data preservation
and access establishing models for the
sustainability and so on I the these
efforts are driven primarily by the
library and information science people
rather than by the computational people
and data net doesn't provide an actual
archive of major data sets I mean the
actual bits are not being stored in the
data net project I think it was from
Tony that I heard the story of the
domesday book is that right I must have
heard it from you where this was a
census taken after after William the
Conqueror so a little after 10 66 and in
the middle 1970s or so they decided you
know this this is a physical book with
pages and it is the census of England
they thought well you know we better
digitize this thing so we can sustain it
for posterity and something like 20
years later there was no reader for the
medium on which they had the digitized
version so this question of data
preservation and sustainability is a
very serious question only there's
another issue and that is that the way
that NSF runs its super computing
program centers come and go and data is
located at sinners simulation data that
is the result of lots of work that
people have done there is no policy and
no sustained effort for data
reservation so if a center disappears we
don't know exactly what happens to the
data so there is an effort by the terror
rid which is sort of the at the moment
the the set of large resources
high-performance computing resources
funded by NSF to have a systematic
effort at archiving data at remote sites
after you make primary copies at at
Pittsburgh we make two copies of the
data for for safety well there's no
reason why the second copy couldn't be
someplace else and we could host a lot
of other people's second copies this is
something that we're thinking about but
it hasn't happened yet NSF has also of
course funded large collaborative
projects built around data so the very
large one in plant science there's a
large one on ocean observatories there's
a earth scope and so on so in various
disciplines they have funded large
collaborative efforts which are
supporting people and sensors and so on
as opposed to large computer analytical
resources so really I I know you guys
have had a long time so this talk is a
little shorter than was was scheduled
let me just summarize the points and
I'll be glad to answer questions there
are many significant scientific drivers
for data-intensive supercomputing in our
view what what's really needed now is
large shared memory machines a better
visualization that's probably going to
be eased by these two recent awards ease
of programming that's of course always
there io better use of national networks
and of course we desperately need better
algorithms for data analysis for
detecting patterns and so on NSF has
recognized these needs and is beginning
to make significant investments I've
told you what's already happened other
things will be coming in the next few
years and of course NSF also puts a lot
of emphasis
on training in every one of their in
every one of their awards so training in
all of the Associated technologies so
thank you very much yes it would it
would simply depend on what it costs I
think yeah
you have skill hostess health about
Michelle
right and we wouldn't I mean when I keep
talking about is really not disc but but
tape maybe maybe right just like we
would have had to move to gallium
arsenide remember that one I don't think
of it in those terms but it's yeah
not in any substantial way well again
data net I think as I understand it is
just developing policies and and and
studying techniques but isn't going to
actually host large collections now I
think Mike is making a very good point
and that is I mean essentially you would
like for four datasets that are widely
accessed you would like to have them in
various places around the country so
that you could you could access them
more quickly
if you look at those experiments of a
betrayal show those within those
experiments they have very collaborative
data repository structures with policies
primary secondary tertiary you heard
stuff here that yesterday oh right right
depressed and and these these large
collaborative efforts that i mentioned
like I plant or or the ocean
observatories and so on again those are
communities they're developing their own
policies and facilities for sharing the
data or for access yeah yeah
well okay you can mention your strong
opinion but I think it go ahead
it's always nice to have somebody else
provided those programs put in a lot of
effort draining but what is really
required this also goes on he teaches a
course consisted by putting all of this
in the one program
right but it's also true that you know
starting with p pack and now with PKS
which are the president's advisory
councils on information technology or
science and technology what have you
there is a perennial call for more
emphasis on the software and i think
that's true and i think that what may be
happening at NSF in the next several
years is a greater emphasis on the
software no i don't think that well i
actually i don't think that is the that
it is where it is generally because it
was generated there is really that I
mean for the super human
well I think you're right and so for
example LSST plans to put all of its
data in in a database that that you can
access and so on so that's certainly
right the other question I would say
also is that for simulated data yet may
be cheaper to simply recompute it when
you need it five years later if you
needed five years later then keep it for
five years
be you do one store the data so you can
find out what's changed 20 years ago so
you have to trade up to about these
issues and he was saying you know he was
trying to remember exactly how he
produced this data separately simulation
settings of this really happy certainly
quite so easy correct right I was mighty
world recently
general view there is tapes is dead
forget tape Scott useless and I'm just
reporting what they said and secondly
that will just read on the experiment
because there's a lot cheaper to keep
the samples and we run the experiment so
it's not even okay in that case papers
dead